this week the chapter involves
revolutions the American Revolution the
French Revolution the Haitian Revolution
with a sort of koto with the period of
Napoleon and a few odds and ends shown
em I've been concerned for some time
about what in the world I have been a
lecture about for this chapter because
this seemed pretty self-evident you know
you have these revolutions they have
ideological resemblances they have the
advantage of spreading over both the new
world in the old world because Haiti
even though it's a short-lived Republic
brings the French Revolution and the
Napoleonic repression to the new world
and so I looked at the other textbooks
in the field and there are three basic
ones that we compete with and two of
them have the same chapter they say well
okay these things belong together
turnout the third one has a totally
different approach and you know I
thought that I would talk about this
difference the one that is different in
approach is a book called the world a
history by Philippe Fernandez our mesto
his is the only currently popular or
successful world history textbook that
is by a single author so it has a
advantage of a single vision in forming
every chapter and of a fairly uniform
style it isn't it is different in many
ways but nowhere I don't think in what
I've read
has it been as different as it is on
this particular subject so that the
American Revolution occurs in chapter 21
which is entitled the age of global
interaction expansion and intersection
of eighteenth-century empires usual sort
of nonsense titles that we give to two
chapters because you know we don't
really have meaningful chapter titles by
and large the French Revolution occurs
in the following chapter
have called the exchange of
Enlightenment's eighteenth-century
thought which is also where Napoleon
hangs out even though he was not an
eighteenth-century figure for the most
part what our mesto does is to to
diminish the what previous historians
have accepted as being the great
significance of the American and the
French Revolutions it is not quite to
the point of trivializing and yet if
presume produces a very very different
impression than what you get from from
virtually every other
book that is anchored in the old concept
of Western Civ which is devoted to the
emergence of the modern world primarily
in or as a appendage to European history
so let me mention here I want to read a
quote from query introduces the American
Revolution which he says very very
little about
he says the experience of military
collaboration between American militias
and British regulars initiated and
exposed cultural differences this is Lee
when the British were and the Americans
were involved in the in the Seven Years
War the French and Indian Wars that
preceded the American Revolution the
floggings and other brutalities of
discipline that troops on the British
Army were subject to repeal the
volunteers in the colonial militias
while the British attacked colonial
resistance to stationing troops in
private houses which was usual practice
elsewhere in the British Empire as
neglect of humanity and depravity of
nature the colonists saw themselves as
trueborn Englishman but were shocked to
find that their fellow countrymen from
across the Atlantic did not share their
self-perception mutual alienation led to
violence there's the beginning of the
Revolutionary War
mutual alienation led to violence
historians used to depict the uprising
in 13 of the English mainland colonies
in the eighteen seven seventeen 70s has
peculiar ly English affair now it was 13
of the English mainland colonies because
of course the Canadian colonies did not
participate in the revolution and so
this is making a an interesting
distinction historians used to depict
this uprising as peculiarly English
affair the inevitable outcome
of long-standing traditions of freedom
that colonists took with them as a
heritage from deep in the English past
on the contrary current scholarship
tells us it was an improvised solution
to short-term problems
a typical convulsion of a colonial world
that was full of rebellions in the late
18th century against the British
government in North in the north of
Ireland against Spain and Colombia and
Peru okay now at this point the American
Revolution has lost all all distinction
it has become simply one of a very very
diverse array of revolutionary movements
or uprising or rebellions or resistances
to colonial authority that are typical
of the 18th century in many different
places
George Washington is mentioned briefly
as the first press trip but in a rather
he said well George Washington wanted to
establish a you know a real foothold for
himself as a planter in the Ohio Valley
but he settled for President of the
Republic instead so now we're and the
other founding father Jefferson actually
gets mentioned but otherwise no one is
mentioned by name and association with
the American Revolution Benjamin
Franklin is mentioned in a different
chapter for his contributions to
scientific thought but the whole story
of of the American Revolution is is left
out of the book this is a you know in
some measure acceptable because all of
the world history textbooks tend to
diminish the position of the United
States on the assumption as I mentioned
the very beginning of the semester on
the assumption that the students who
take world history are taking or have
taken or will take American history and
that therefore you don't have to give
the details of American history and yet
as the story moves forward it becomes
increasingly difficult to leave the
United States out because when you get
say to to World War One or World War two
or the Cold War or more recent events
the centrality of the United States
becomes something that you cannot simply
write around the u.s. is there it is
playing a major role in every part of
history around the world so you can't
leave it out so the question is when do
you put it in do you leave out the
revolution
and leave out the civil war and then
have America appear on the scene let us
say in the time of the spanish-american
war when the u.s. becomes an imperial
power at the same time engaging in
efforts to intervene in affairs in South
America okay it's it's a question and
that's a legitimate question when do you
put the United States in and how do you
put it in you can make an argument for
for minimizing it but perhaps it's
harder to make an argument for
trivializing it which is in a sense what
comes up here although in a later
chapter he talks about the United States
as developing institutions that are very
different from the institutions that
arose from all the other rebellions that
happened in the 18th century but that
isn't part of the story here it's as if
you can say you're saying that the
colonists rebelled against Britain
because Britain was in their view
oppressive and they'd had a increasing
distance arising between the colonists
and British government and people back
in Britain and that that was a typical
late 18th century thing to do
and then later on without ever
explaining exactly how it happened you
say as it happened the American
rebellion produced a stable government
democratic institutions the president
first president did not become a
dictator or a king and so you you then
say well you
had a different outcome which then goes
back to the original question if if if
the outcome is different
should the outcome have guided the
narrative into getting at the root of
why the outcome was was different and
that's where you go back to the what he
calls here the the traditional narrative
of being rooted in traditions of freedom
and rights and so forth that had been
developed in England over a period of
time basically since the English
revolution of the mid 1600s all right
that's what he does with the American
Revolution now you go on to the next
chapter and you get to the French
Revolution here's how he introduces that
story to those who endured it or
experienced its consequences the revenue
the revolution that according to the
conventional narrative broke out in
France on the 14th of July 1789 when the
Bastille fell seemed so momentous that
they searched the past for its causes
historians have looked deep into the
history of the pre-revolutionary old
regime in France for explanations like
most political upheavals however the
French Revolution arose suddenly in the
particular circumstances of the time and
unrolled rapidly and ways previously
unforeseeable so again it's it it just
happened you know
American soldiers found that they really
didn't like the way the British Army
operated and you go a decade or two
farther and something breaks out and the
American Revolution just happens French
Revolution just happens or circumstances
you need to tell something about the
circumstances and the calling of the
estates-general and so on but it's clear
that there is a an explicit attempt to
to get away from the notion that the
French Revolution has a such a
monumental importance that it needs to
have a backstory that it needs to have a
lengthy historical explanation as to why
did this monumental event occur in
traditional Western Civ European history
that story is told at great length
they're very very different opinions as
to how that story should be told but
it's a
it's a way of affirming the historical
perception that this French Revolution
was a particular importance the same
thing can be said of the American
Revolution that if you see it as a
monumental event in world history then
you are the your warranted look at its
historical antecedents its roots its
wide that's ever occurred and this is an
alternative that that really portrays it
as kind of you know something that damn
it just happened and and that's what
history that's what happens in history I
mean you you can say of virtually every
historical event as he says here
like most political upheavals it rose
suddenly in the particular circumstances
a time and unrolled rapidly in ways
previously unforeseeable this is a
description that could be applied to
everything that has happened in history
the question of the the developments of
political people being unforeseeable
well
are there has there ever been any
political developments that are
unperceivable I mean foresight is really
not something that works any human
affairs very well so so then you get to
a later part of the chapter and he he
says the French Revolution was part of
the dark side of the Enlightenment both
in its creation and its destroyer by you
conveniens Napoleon it opened with noble
cries of liberty equality fraternity the
Rights of Man and of the citizen
sovereignty of the people he ended with
a sickening scream that forms the last
line of the Marseillaise the French
revolutionaries anthem calling for
troughs full of the impure blood of
aristocrats traders and foreigners okay
the dark side of the Enlightenment oh he
then follows this up at the sentence the
Enlightenment survived in America
whether the dark side or the light side
he doesn't specify at this point in the
book the idea that the Enlightenment has
a dark side has gained a great deal of
headway in the last generation virtually
any work by Michel Foucault
is devoted to showing the dark side of
the enlightenment largely by saying that
once you create the notion that
rationality is supreme and it governs
everything and everything therefore
should be precisely measured categorized
labelled and treated scientifically that
you end up creating monstrous you know
monstrous things and irrational
divisions even though they claim to be
rational so forth and so on and I won't
try and give any of fuko's arguments but
it's a it's a view that that has become
quite common to see that enlightenment
thought had some you know some some deep
flaws but to say that the French
Revolution was part of the dark side of
the Enlightenment I'm kind of an amazing
proposition first even though he has
already said that like most political
upheavals it appeared suddenly in
particularly circumstances and developed
in ways previously unforeseeable by
saying it's the dark side of the
Enlightenment it implies that the
Enlightenment is in some way connected
with the French Revolution but the
alignment comes before the French
Revolution is it the historical
background of the French Revolution well
since he's denied that there's any need
to study the historical background
you're left sort of up in the air if it
if it just happened and it turned out
that it was really bad you know then
well that that was simply the way things
worked out on the other hand if it's a
dark side of the Enlightenment there
seems to be an implication that you
should study the Enlightenment in order
to to understand
where the french revolution came from
and of course the title of the chapter
in which he discusses this is the
exchange of Enlightenment 18th century
thought when you get into his
development of the French Revolution as
a narrative which is very brief it turns
out there is only he mentions
Robespierre but the only other thinker
that he mentions and the one who is
granted the most space is a the Marquis
de Sade who is one of the people
liberated from the Bastille and any he
goes on at some length about the the the
celebration of Liberty that you have
with desaad but Liberty in sort of the
the sense of libertine ISM that a
Liberty that is a sexual Liberty and not
a strictly a political Liberty sort of
what you get in that that great chorus
from Don Giovanni where you'll viva la
libertad where you know he's going into
to the ballroom where there's going to
be an orgy presumably and he was bad guy
but some people say well that's actually
Mozart saying and his librettist saying
liberty is what it's what we need and
Don Giovanni or Don Juan sort of saying
well liberty is what I want so I'm ended
up being very confused by what it is
that the author here is trying to is
trying to convey
and when you get to his to his sort of
final comments it opened with noble
cries of liberty equality and fraternity
actually that didn't happen liberty
libert galit a fraternity become the
slogan of the French Republic the third
French Republic after 1850 the phrase
shows up in one instance at the time of
the Revolution and otherwise there are
many other phrases that show up usually
in groups of three
but liberty equality fraternity is is
not one doesn't show up in the in the
statement of the Rights of Man and so
forth and indeed the whole question of
what does fraternity mean is one that
you know if one were an intellectual
historian would be worth would be worth
asking when it occurred at the time of
the French Revolution in the one place
where it shows up that we know of
it is a lot of battlecry perhaps but
it's certainly the slogan of a
particular military formation and it
seems fairly clear that fraternity is
talking about the Solidarity of the
military group you know we are all
brothers in arms if you have the word a
gal eat a what in the world you need
fraternity for you know we're all equal
and we're brothers well if you're all
equal you need to add on that you're all
brothers it turns out that that
particular word gets tossed around for
the next couple of generations and
trying to decide you know what it what
it means because it turns out that there
are Catholic thinkers who say this
refers to you know Brotherhood in Christ
and that that it's a way of referring to
the fundamental of Christian
underpinnings you know we are we want
Liberty we're equal because God created
us but as far as we're brothers
it's brothers in in Christ then you've
got the Socialists and they see it
returned ETA as being sort of comrade
citizen and they see it as a social
leveling thing which you would think
would already be implied by the word
eagle eat a but they see it as we must
have revolutionary solidarity which is
which is expressed by the word brother
I remember in the the time of the
Iranian Revolution in 1979 there was
some reason why I had to go to the
Iranian embassy in Washington which was
at that time before the hostage crisis
and so forth was still occupied because
we still had diplomatic relations and it
was striking how everyone in the embassy
addressed everyone else as Mirada the
Persian word for brother you know or
because Persian which has the most
elegant and refined hierarchy of terms
for making you feel diminished sometimes
said that to Iranians we'll know within
the first three sentence of an exchange
which is of a higher social rank because
of the that the forms of language that
are used I don't understand it but I
take take this as given but but
certainly all of the all of these
precious refinements that you had in
Persian had disappeared because in the
revolution everyone is a brother and a
sister and that of course raised
question a brother and a sister in what
in a family presumably but is it a
family of Iranians or is it the family
of the Islamic faith because there are
these ambiguities as to what is the
broader context so that in Muslim
political organizations knew very fine
you very commonly find people referring
to one another as brother and sister as
you do in in Christian congregations
certain of them so so our mesto starts
out with by saying that here is this
French Revolution
starts out with noble cries and he
simply goes along with Lee with the
conventional narrative as he calls it
and says that Liberte egalite and
Fraternite a was what are these noble
cries even though if it actually wasn't
and it's not very hard to find the
historical details that will show you
that it wasn't and then it ends up in
the sickening scream that forms the last
line of the Marseillaise
to arms citizens form your battalions
March March
let impure blood water our furrows and
it's this notion of impure blood sang
Emperor that obviously is upset him but
it's actually rather interesting to read
the Marseillaise many of you have
probably sung it or have heard it sung
and one of the things that I am pretty
sure is that you've only heard the first
first son there are five six more verses
what do they want this horde of slaves
of traders in conspiratorial Kings for
whom these vile chains these long
prepared irons Frenchmen for us ah what
outrage what methods must be taken
it is us they dare plan to return to the
old slavery and what these foreign
cohorts they would make laws in our
courts what these mercenary phalanxes
would cut down our warrior sons
good lord by chained hands our brow
would yield under the yoke the vile
despots would have themselves be the
masters of destiny
so yes it's a martial poem against
people who are described here as slaves
traders and conspiratorial kings but
then you go on to a couple of verses
farther and it says Frenchmen as
magnanimous warriors bear or hold back
your blows spare these sad victims that
they regret taking up arms against us
suddenly the the message is reversed and
saying be magnanimous do not kill people
wanton Lee just because they are
fighting against you spare these sad
victims that they regret taking up arms
against us but not these bloody despots
these accomplishments these accomplices
accomplices of bluee all these Tigers
who pitilessly ripped out their mothers
wombs No
this is a concern to me because my
family name is often pronounced boo yay
and indeed my grandfather let it be
understood
totally incorrectly that he was a French
man of Arts and Letters who had come to
America and become a newspaper art
critic in the Middle West and he was
always addressed as mr. boo yay whereas
during the three months of the year when
he lived in southern Indiana with his
wife and son he was Clarence bullet
country Jake from Coradin and so he had
a kind of a double life
he was a dirty French roue and Chicago
and a country boy in southern Indiana
and there's always been a question in
the family whether we should accept the
pronunciation whoo yay or not in fact my
my grandfather in
pursuing his interest in becoming a
French man of letters and arts James the
spelling of last name from AIT
to IET so that you could pronounce it
boo yay
because it was AIT it everybody
pronounce the bullet all my AIT can
pronounce a bullet if you like bullet
bourbon which is one of the best
Bourbons in the country and it's spelled
AIT those are my cousins who whom I've
never met who brewed the Bourbon I came
from the Methodist side of the family
that did not drink ah
presumably they stuck with the old
Catholic side of a family that drank
like fish I don't know but in any case
boo this business of not these bloody
despots those these accomplices of
Bouvier all these Tigers who pitilessly
ripped out their mothers wombs well it
turns out that the Marquis de boulier
was the man who was in communication
with louis xvi on you know in eastern
france and was prepared to help him
escape and combat the revolution from
abroad he had fought in the Seven Years
War as a governor of a colony in in the
Caribbean and he had a history of
fighting against the British but he was
a patriotic loyalist and would have
helped the king escape if they had not
been if the royal family had not been
waylaid and captured on their way to the
to the rendezvous so then he became the
object of scoring because he was seen as
a as a
as a true trader he was also a cousin of
Lafayette so a French nobleman the
Marseillaise in other words is you know
arose as a fighting song in that sort of
moment of trying to defend the the New
Republic against conspiracies that were
being hatched from abroad and who yeh
became a you know emblematic of that
sort of thing he was a traitor and he
was going to bring in foreigners to
fight against France so forth and so on
whether this is qualifies at the last
line of marcio's as a sickening scream I
think is is a very you know very much
open to interpretation so what I I don't
want to go further with with this attack
on Professor mesto because I'm not
interested in it as an attack but rather
as a different way of looking at at
history in two respects
first an effort to D canonize events
that have been taken in what he calls
the conventional narrative as the
monumental events at the end of the 18th
century that more or less laid the
foundations for what would come in the
in the in the 19th century
d canonization is a complicated process
I mean what is a cannon a cannon is a
set of received opinions or beliefs or
theories that are so broadly accepted
and so rarely challenged that you just
accept them as being true we run into
the issue of cannons in various ways in
in history most obvious one of course is
what constitutes the cannon in a
religious tradition now who determined
what books would be in the Old Testament
and what books would be in the New
Testament and so we call we call these
canons but then in more recent times
we've gotten into huge debates over
things like the Columbia core curriculum
and the question of whether there are
certain writings that are by Universal
consensus so important that they
constitute a Canon that everybody has to
know them this is the foundation of our
lit hum and all of our major core
courses is that we have a Canon that
everyone should know these things
but that Canon is very particular to to
Columbia you would have it seen very
differently at many other universities I
think when I had joined when I joined
the faculty at Columbia I had read none
of the works on the CC or little Canon
and I thought gosh I'm a tenured
professor at the University it feels
that you cannot even because
decently be a graduate
unless you've read these works because
they're so important and I hadn't read
them so so I proceeded to get a Columbia
education by teaching CC and live home
in a Hart home and music hum because it
was the only way I was going to catch up
with what Columbia undergraduates were
expected to know because of the
educational institution I went to we
didn't have a notion of a Canon we
didn't have a very good undergraduate
education either but it was it was the
notion there was something that
everybody should know was very very
questionable a number of years later a
man named Edie Hirsch came up with an
idea of that you should have cultural
literacy that everyone every student in
the country should be tested to see how
literate they were in terms of
contemporary or American culture and
they would have certain things they
would have to know and he created a
dictionary of cultural literacy and he
wanted to institute a test this that
would check on cultural literacy this
was very popular in very conservative
circles in the country I remember when
he applied for an neh grant I was on the
panel that had to review it and I think
I argued for two or three hours against
it and then they passed it anyway
because I thought it was a very bad idea
because everything on me in the cultural
literacy turned out what sort of things
that white folks would know and the
whole movement of toward having a more
polyvalent appreciation of American
society seemed to go in the opposite
direction from this that would require
that everyone know a certain
a certain set of things a cannon but
then you have a question of de
canonization if you have something that
has that's universally accepted can you
get rid of it or should you get rid of
it
and if you if you can get rid of it
what would be the matter of doing this
there have been a number of successful
efforts Indy canonization in the
historical profession for example the
term Dark Ages has virtually disappeared
you can refer to Dark Ages as long as
they're not European but the European
Dark Ages following the fall of Rome
the term has been pretty much retired
there has been a strong effort to get
rid of the term feudal in feudalism that
has not succeeded medieval European
medieval us have said that everything
implied by the word feudalism in terms
of a way of managing political and
economic and hierarchical relations in
medieval Europe is wrong the things that
are ascribed to feudalism were the
invention of lawyers 200 years later
when they were trying to sort out
property issues and they never existed
nevertheless the word feudalism by that
time had been applied to Japan and been
applied to lots of other places and Marx
had picked it up and talked about a
feudal era and turned out you couldn't
get rid of that word so in in some ways
if it seemed like it was easier to layer
a word on to an existing Canon or to
layer a new master narrative onto an
existing Canon then it was to get rid of
the of the old understanding
well I've yeah I've tried this myself I
wrote a book called the case for Islamic
Christian civilization where I invented
the word Islamic Christian civilization
and ever since I case we will google it
and see how many people are using the
term the word I expected it to be a
growth curve like that and it's been a
growth curve like that it's very very
slow nevertheless the whole idea was to
to put a new term into circulation and
see what what utility it might serve
okay what what is going on here with
with our mesto relates to the creation
of Atlantic history can say there there
were three related historical well four
I suppose related historical narratives
master narratives there was a history of
Europe there was a history of of North
America England you know
english-speaking America there was a
history of a span of latin america
spanish from portuguese speaking america
and there was a history of africa each
of those histories had a strong
essentially local developed in other
words American Historians for a very
long time really didn't care about
anything that happened outside the
United States it was American history
same thing with Latin American history
same thing with African history but
increasingly
historians got into the into the
question of dyadic relationships where
they take two of these things and they
talk about resident how did Africa
relate to Latin America in the Caribbean
through slavery how did Africa relate to
North America through slavery how did
Europe relate to South America via
Spanish and Portuguese Enterprise how
did Europe relate to North America
through British and to some degree
French enterprise these things then
became related I am more and more
complex ways until within the last
several decades you've had an increasing
tendency to talk about Atlantic history
and to take the Atlantic Ocean
originally I think it was North Atlantic
as in North Atlantic Treaty Organization
but but increasingly now it's termed
Atlantic history to take that as a as a
almost a symbol or a some sort of
abstract site through which lines of
communication and influence and contact
connect but the ocean itself contributes
minimally to to this it's simply the
thing that divides the pioneering effort
along these lines was a 19th century
effort to create the Mediterranean as a
space that was a simultaneously a
connector and a divider and we have a
long history of people trying to do
Mediterranean history and
that has become a very lively field of
the present time there is there was some
interest in the idea of doing Saharan
history where you would take a desert
rather than an ocean and you would say
well that is something that that
connects and divides and we can treat it
as an ocean and see how the the coastal
areas of the sahara desert from north
africa down to the Sahel area how they
interrelate it became harder with other
bodies of water or other areas because
they were not enclosed became harder to
conceive of of the Indian Ocean because
you didn't go around the Indian Ocean it
just had serve northwest northeast and
arc between them South China Sea was
another one that didn't quite gel in the
same way the Red Sea has had no history
in this sort of meta historical sense
the Black Sea very little so the
Atlantic Ocean is not the first body of
water to be identified as the label for
some kind of complex of historical
relations people who are opposed to the
idea of Atlantic history seem to be more
often Europeans and Americans presumably
because if you have Atlantic history it
makes the Americas much more important
than if you simply have the old European
history or history of Western
civilization
there has been an extremely strong push
for this among Latin Americanist Latin
Americanist have for a long time felt
that they do not gain sufficient
recognition by American historians or
sufficient recognition by European
historians so they have been very
interested in this so when you look at
the literature on theorizing the
Atlantic you not surprisingly find a
fair number of Latin American Historians
involved but this would be a kind of
layering of a new master narrative on
top of the old ones what our mesto does
is a little bit different he seems to be
come closer to the notion of D
canonizing something in other words
instead of saying well the American
Revolution was important and it had
major impacts because 19th 20th century
history would be profoundly different if
you had not had the American Republic in
the French Revolution was important
because even though it was brought to an
end by Napoleon the impact for 19th 20th
century history of the French Revolution
is very very strong
instead of saying we'll let us accept
the importance of these things and then
layer on to it a different perspective
that would come from from an Atlanta
cyst view and show more comparisons with
South America and the Caribbean more
comparisons with other things happening
in Europe some scholars now are looking
at 18th century rebellions everywhere in
the world rather than simply the
Atlantic and they're going beyond the
notion of an Atlantic paradigm
but as I say this appears to be more of
the effort of D canonization to to
diminish the importance of things
previously held to be important rather
than to recognize that importance and to
layer some other additional spirit
perspective onto it but I find it an
intriguing effort that so one of the
things that I see here is a D
canonization another one is a style that
is very very much an ex cathedra style
one where the author says here is the
way things are this was largely
rhetorical it has to do with style the
author who says that French Revolution
was part of the dark side of the
Enlightenment now to simply say that
flat-out without saying you know what
does that mean
be the dark side of the Enlightenment as
a stylistic choice all right
I've been criticizing a book other than
my own which is not what I'm supposed to
be doing but when I come to my own book
which is very much the conventional
narrative we we tell about the American
Revolution the French Revolution the
Haitian Revolution the chapter was
written by my colleague Lyman Johnson
who is a specialist on Latin America and
who feels very strongly that the
ideological roots of the French American
and Haitian revolutions are not closely
related to the ideological roots of the
various revolutions that you have in
Latin America and he feels that was a
fad among Latin Americanist
you know 20 years ago but that now new
interpretations are seeing greater
difference here but at the end of our
chapter Johnson writes an interesting
paragraph very short these revolutions
began the transformation of Western
society but they did not complete it
only a minority gained full political
rights women did not achieve full
political rights until the 20th century
democratic institutions as in
revolutionary France often failed
moreover slavery endured in the Americas
past the mid-1800s despite the
revolution E air Revolutionary eras
enthusiasm for individual liberty
now to say it began the transformation
of Western society is very close to - to
adopting explicitly a sort of Telos for
the narrative saying you know the big
story that we're going to have here is
the emergence of quote Western society
unquote and Western society will be
marked by political rights gender
equality democratic institutions and
abolition of slavery these will be the
hallmarks of Western society
I don't know what he was thinking
first of all one of the most crucial
aspects that he does not mention as
being part of Western society is the
issue of secularism relationship of a
state of our religion and society or
religion the state he could easily have
put it in and he he chose not to but
beyond that is Western society really
what the story is you know where do you
put for example totalitarianism you know
are you on the road to Western society
and then oops there's the Nazis or you
know we are going the way to having
democracy oh dear there came another
dictator or you know those Communists
took over in Russia what are gonna do
about them you know is he suggesting
here that there is a master narrative
that is involved with the emergence of
Western society and that even though
it's not complete when these revolutions
are accomplished we're on the way that
this is this is troubling and I fully
expect to persuade Lyman not to include
this paragraph in his next revision of
the chapter because I think that it is
that is being too
- explicit in a in a preference for a
certain type of society which I don't
see any warrant to call Western
so in a sense what is in my textbook is
sort of at the other end of the spectrum
from what is in the world history of
fernando's are messed up as to say you
have a my book is much more inclined in
this stage in this chapter to go with a
traditional narrative with a long
accepted perception that there are
certain monumental events that require
special attention and with Fernando
Zahra mesto you'll get the notion that
those monumental events should be should
be reduced to sort of molehill size and
they should not be linked to one another
because they're just the result of local
circumstances at a particular point in
time that should not be woven into some
sort of grand picture of civilizational
development at the beginning of this
semester I said that a lot of the
problems that I would be having and
thinking about matters in this half of
the course would have to do with the
notion of modernity
virtually everyone talks about the
modern world modern society will
guarantee and so forth but it is much
more difficult to define what in the
world that amounts to so when when a
book talks about a transformation of
Western society that's going to be based
on political rights gender equality
democratic institutions and abolition of
slavery abolition of the color bar is
are these aspects of modernity and is
that what we should be
should be focusing on I mean
or is there another way to have to look
at these matters we'll explore some of
this in some in some later chapters now
the one thing that I haven't gotten into
is the the thing that's common between
our and fernando's our mesto version of
it and that is the impact of Napoleon
here you have the man who takes over the
French Republic turns it into an empire
and until 1815 is the great change maker
in European history while the French
Revolution may appear to be just some
events that happened and the American
Revolution can be just well a sort of
thing that happens when our soldiers
don't like this
Napoleon does not become romatic in this
sense he simply zoos and the strides
Europe indeed the strides the world as a
major figure the
there's a section of the Harvard library
that is devoted to imaginary Wars it
works if somebody had a collection they
gave it to Harvard and it sits on the
bottom floor of Widener Library and they
are novels about wars that never
occurred and it's a
not very recent collection of books but
20 little you find that throughout the
19th century after 1815 the notion of
the return of Napoleon or of the French
under a new Napoleon invading England we
again and again and again the image of
Napoleon is vastly I can't say it's
greater than the reality because the
reality was very important it's just
that it long outlast is that Napoleon
easily accomplished in the same way that
the image of Adolf Hitler has eclipsed
Napoleon and long outlasted you know the
horrible things that he that he
accomplished there was a New Yorker
occasional by Bruce McCall a number of
years ago he said that one day Hitler
came into the meeting of his top
lieutenants and he had no clothes on
they all have heard of their own he said
no no no don't bring your eyes from now
on we are all going to go naked eye and
he said do you want to know why and they
said of course you won't know why well
what is our our secret deepest desire
they said ah to establish the
thousand-year Reich and change the world
rule the world said no no need for that
deepa that okay to kill every Jew and
make the entire world that our objective
no no no beyond that and they were
puzzled and finally he said it's to be
the greatest plot device in history and
we are just conquerors and just
murderers will be like Napoleon oh shut
up because we'll be superseded by some
worse
you're coming along but if we all go
naked it will catch the imagination of
every fiction writer and we will be
forever the greatest plot device in
history
yep them just like to share that with
you if someone who's actually written at
least one novel relating to an imaginary
will write very much aware of how these
plot devices are used okay so here you
have two monuments that's that one in
the interest of newer approaches to
history an Atlantic focus and so forth
one can seek to minute to canonize them
because they are maybe simply are
commercial of movements or rebellions or
positions to imperialism that are
occurring in other parts of the world in
the late 18th century but then here's
napoleon who stands out now would say
you know strongmen using military
techniques particularly well all over
the place at the turn of the of the 19th
century you have military dictators in
latin america ii you know the great
leader of the slave rebellion in the
haiti of new Bertier the success a man
who comes to style himself as never you
have people in the Middle East who are
clearly impressed by the example of
Napoleon but actually would have been
moving in the direction without that
particular example that totalitarianism
where the root are present and
ubiquitous simultaneously now the roots
of democracy or what in society do that
then can get into this question as to
whether whether the story that you're
going to tell of the 19th and 20th 21st
century is a story of the rights
oriented democratic growth of Western
society or the story of the growth of of
totalitarianism
which of these is is the more important
thread to follow should when follow them
and adopt some other metric or some
other approach that would sort of put
some kind of a in lecture but one of the
reasons I want to to mention this now is
that
to the Arab Spring
can be looked at as like most political
upheavals arising suddenly in the
particular circumstances of the time and
then rolling rapidly in ways previously
unforeseeable okay
in other words the Arab Spring you can
say just happened like the French
Revolution yeah it just happened you had
local circumstances American Revolution
you know mutual alienation they start
fighting so forth in the other hand
everyone in my profession is currently
busy trying to explain where the Arab
Spring came from myself it seems very
difficult to argue that this just
happened there must be antecedents there
must be associations you know he would
say it's Facebook other people would say
it's the example of perhaps the Iranian
Revolution other people would say it's
the you know the devious operations of
radical Islamists so forth and so on but
you know I'm living through something
that appears likely to be in its
long-term impact
it's very difficult for me to see how
you can adopt a an addict of well it's
just it's just happening and so I
anything of whether that's an adequate
approach for things whether you you can
take D canaanites them refute their
apparent monumentality simply saying
that this is what happens in human life
okay
when you get political upheaval and they
come about because of circumstances and
those assets are not foreseeable becomes
foreseeable it raises a question of what
is it that historians do right or do
they narrate or which is I think what is
involved here do they try to introduce a
grander structure that takes the story
the narrative of the realm of political
explanation and puts it in a much much
broader context perhaps a broader
context chronologically a broader
context geographically I could imagine
someone perhaps someday saying well the
Arab Spring was a part of the you know
what was a political upheaval that was
one of many around the world because of
course there are political upheavals in
other parts of the world and that it
fundamentally relates to a globalization
of the economy yep well probably does I
mean everything makes globalization the
economy those but you know I think you'd
have a very hard time selling that as an
explanatory argument at this point in
time it is more the sort of thing that
arises from historical hindsight and
that is what we really have here is a
contest between a political conventional
narrative which my book more or less
subscribes to that grows out of
arguments about causation and patterns
of political development that have been
debated from the day
dunphy a development onward for you know
250 years as opposed to the idea that
you disregard that seeing in less to
parochial but instead you try and put
something in a mega historical structure
of a of a sort that is more perceptible
to the historian perhaps than to the
reader and you come up with your
conclusions in sort of a ex cathedra
manner saying you know here's what
happened the French Revolution was the
dark side of the Enlightenment so I will
continue on
I hope not in this particular vein
because it sort of wandered throughout
the body but I'll continue on in this
chapter on Thursday
I've got the answer to your attic break